I recognize all of my sharks they look
to me different a slaughter classroom
full of students there's nothing that
makes me more relaxed and happier than
have one of the girls come in and rest
in my lap the things that extreme a
privileged and wild animal is feeling
comfortable enough to relax at that
level
[Music]
my name is Christina Donato I work as a
diving professional and I specialize in
working with sharks in the wild
specifically Caribbean reef sharks I
have received many nicknames a through
the years it is usually shark dancer
just because of the a gentle and soft
interaction that I have with them and
mother of sharks because I have there's
a protective attitude towards them so I
came to the Bahamas about 26 years ago
to learn how to scuba dive and now take
people down one on one with me and we
talked about shark behavior and
especially interacting with Caribbean
reef sharks I've been in the same
location working with a group of sharks
for 26 years since I've been able to
watch them through the years with time I
actually can recognize them as they swim
towards me from a distance they have
very different personalities your body
language the way they approach me the
way they interact with me each one of
them has their unique way of doing
the Bahamas or a special place for
sharks
I created a petition of name 2009 asking
the government to start protecting the
Sharks and ultimately in 2011 the
Bahamas were declared a shark sanctuary
no sharks can be killed within our
waters or no import-export nor use of
any of the shark products something I'm
very proud to have contributed by being
one of those Eva that has attracted the
world to come here and see our sharks
and die with them
not every shark not even sharks that a
work wave for the last ten years likes
to be pet and in some other sharks
sometimes put themselves to sleep but
just coming up to me nuzzling up into my
other my stomach or my back or my leg
and just sit in there when they do that
out of me surges love I absolutely love
my sharks the acceptance and the trust
that they give me is it's a privilege
it's so beautiful
they are nature's masterpiece one of the
most beautiful masterpieces ever created
[Music]